but we're going to start today with
golden knights hockey it was the vegas
golden knights
taking on the avalanche back to back
games and how about this feasting on
shark yesterday today they flew home to
face
colorado first of three straight this
week over the next six days against the
avalanche
these two teams are two of the top three
teams in the national hockey league
the knights the abs and the lightning
the top teams at the sports books
hey and they're not wrong very often
this was a good game kind of what you
would expect from
two of the best teams grinding and
treasure in every possession
max pacquiao nearly scores right here on
the power play hits the post that's how
close it was with a wrist shot
in the second off the assist zach white
cloud pacioretty blows one by they're on
the board
stone just enough of distraction out
front max's seventh of the season
but could vegas hang on to that lead
midway through the second
jason megna comes oh face to face with
fleury same thing though
how about the third here the abs were
pressuring marc-andre
and he was her best player on the ice
night look at all the commotion out in
front fleury with 30 saves late in the
third
a former knight has a shot on goal
pierre edward belmar
but he is turned away fleury might be
the best goalie in the league right now
vegas beats the abs one to nothing was
the final
so the knights in the avalanche playing
in a kind of game you'd expect there
two of the top teams battling for top
honors in the west let's get the latest
now here's kevin martin
yeah thanks chris a huge grind out win
for the golden knights over the
avalanche who were playing their first
game since february 3rd because of the
nhl covid protocol and the story of the
game
was marc-andre fleury who made his
fourth straight start tonight in net
recording his second
shutout of the season turning away all
30 of colorado's shots on goldman vgk to
their 10th win of the season
and the top spot in the west division
flurry now picks up back-to-back wins
which is both rewarding
and exhausting i don't know it's been a
while i don't think it's part of routine
uh feeling feeling it in the legs a bit
right now but
um that's fun you know fun to uh
to get some wins here and uh being a
good team today
it was fantastic and um he was fantastic
last yesterday in san jose too um
i i think when you look at our schedule
and and with uh
robin going down you know we've asked
them to play
a bunch of games in a row here and uh
you know he's
uh he's had the energy to do it and
you know and and not only do it but do
it at a really high level
he's been our best player through this
stretch so uh
you know got to get him some rest and
get them ready for tuesday
those who are keeping count this is the
63rd career shutout and 473rd career win
for the 36 year old goaltender and
as you just heard head coach pete deboer
say with no word or
status on robin leonard and that upper
body injury it appears mark
andre fleury will be getting his fifth
straight start on tuesday
chris